ce soir on sera tellement de vampire que
toute la ville sera à nous vive la
mariée
[Musique]
j'étais une fête et une petite nana qui
m'a mordu récapitule tu as été mortu au
coup tu es devenu allergique au soleil
et t'aime plus les frites à l'ail je
crois que tu es devenu amour
c'était mon seul t-shirt propre désolé
je me sens pas
déco va falloir se rendre à l'évidence
mais vous êtes malade
pourquoi vous avez voulu tuer mon frère
tu as une photo de la fille qui m'a
mordu au cou la femme qui est à mordu
c'est ma fiancée elle aussi c'est un
vampire et si tu t'es transformé c'est à
cause d'elle je veux que vous
m'appreniez à tuer les vampires
bien
[Musique]
chez l'organisme une grande fête ce soir
ce serait l'occasion rêvée de nous
débarrasser d'elle
vite vite vite vite
tu te rends compte que tu as tué
beaucoup de gens
sur les mains maintenant quoi tu as du
sang sur les mains tu devrais les laver